ADAM WILLIAMS: Hello, everybody.
My name's Adam Williams.
I'm the chef over at Grace
Hopper here in Cambridge.
And I am pleased to introduce
to you a local chef here
in Boston, a
restaurateur recently
named "Time's" Most
Influential People 2017,
the pride of South Boston--
I can easily say that--
and author of her new
memoir, "Out of Line--
a Life of Playing with Fire."
Please welcome Chef Barbara
Lynch to Talks at Google.
[APPLAUSE]
BARBARA LYNCH: Thanks, Andrew.
Thanks for waiting.
I'm a shitty driver.
I think it's time
to get a driver.
Got a speeding ticket this trip.
OK.
I'm just going to read
a little excerpt, when
I opened Menton, which was
just about 10 years ago.
"As 2009 wore on, I was
getting anxious to open Menton.
It's too soon, people
kept telling me.
But I noticed that Boston,
like every other city
in the country, is
full of steakhouses
where it costs as
much to eat hunks
of meat from huge
commercial feedlots,
plain old baked potatoes,
and iceberg lettuce
while drinking ordinary booze
and wine at sky-high mark-ups
as it might cost
to dine at Menton.
Of course, some
steakhouses are special.
But often, you pay
top dollar for a meal
you could easily make at
home on the backyard grill.
Compare that typical
steakhouse meal
with a fine dining experience--
with food that
awakens your palate
paired with expertly
chosen wines delivered
through flawless service,
which is more worth the price.
During the recession,
the steakhouses
didn't go broke,
because people always
need a place where they
can celebrate with food.
They might be too intimidated
to choose a high-end restaurant,
fearing a stuffy atmosphere,
snooty service, or food
that's too fancy or weird.
I understand that, which
is why we need warm,
unpretentious places where
people can discover and delight
in the new.
I wanted Menton to be
one of those places--
a welcoming setting
with stimulating food.
And I also felt a sense of
responsibility to Boston.
A world class has restaurants
where innovation is always
going on.
They're in a central part
of the cultural landscape.
It was a sin that
we'd lost so many.
And young chefs
need kitchens where
they can observe and start
to experiment with flavors
while stretching their
techniques beyond bistro food.
When I announced the
launch in December,
the "Boston Globe"
wondered if I was doomed.
In a piece called "The
Gambler in the Kitchen,"
Bella English ticked
off some reasons why.
I was launching an ultra-lavish
restaurant in a weak economy
that has shuttered other upscale
establishments in the middle
of winter--
normally an off-time
in the industry--
and in a four-point
channel neighborhood,
an area that has yet to
truly take off commercially.
The upshot-- this time she's
defying convention as never
before.
But I went ahead, and
I pulled the trigger.
Menton opened in spring 2010.
In April, the "Globe" gave us
a housewarming gift that still
gives me a shiver of joy--
a two-page review-- a rave
review in its Sunday magazine.
Devra First, the
reviewer, praised,
'The ravioli stuffed
with fava leaf,
truffles flung about like
rose petals at a wedding,
fois gras terrene richness
punctuated by sweet wine jelly,
squiggles of rhubarb
[INAUDIBLE] exuberantly
on the plate.'"
She's such a writer.
"'A pea veloute the color
of Kermit pools around candy
colors, tiny pink radishes,
bright carrots, asparagus tips,
elephant mushrooms, spiced
with wisps of curry yogurt,
fat langoustines with blunt,
pink tails wrapped in shredded
phyllo dough.'" Wow,
she really did like it.
"'It was downright poetic.
A pool [INAUDIBLE], a menu
offering maximum pleasure.'
And that was my goal, exactly
what I wanted to achieve.
One paragraph that grabbed
me discussed the controversy
about the opening--
whether it was arrogant to
open an expensive high-end
restaurant in tough times.
Devra First didn't think so
and credited the nerve it took.
'Chef Barbara Lynch,' she
wrote, 'has canals of steel.
Men have balls of
steel, but how do
you say that a woman
is bold for a chef?
What expression
could be better?'
I'd like 'she had canal of
steel' to be my epitaph.
Menton would be listed
in the best restaurant
round-ups in "Bon Apetit"
and end in "Esquire"
and be nominated for the best
new restaurant at the 2011
James Beard Awards.
Then amazingly,
the restaurant was
included into
Relais and Chateaux,
the prestigious
international consortium
of gourmet restaurants
and boutique hotels.
Sophisticated travelers pay
a substantial fee to join,
in order to ensure
that wherever they are,
they can enjoy
the finest quality
accommodations and meals.
Restaurants are
admitted because of
their innovative cuisine and
outstanding service, confirmed
by surprise visits of
the 520 chefs scattered
over five continents.
Only 35 are in
the United States.
And I was the only one in
Boston and one of the only six
female chefs in the world.
All I could say was, holy
shit, I really fucking did it."
Sorry.
"Then I went out, and I got
the heaviest, most beautiful,
gold plaque I could
find to hang out
front with the Relais
and Chateaux designation
in bold lettering.
I could just hear my mother
saying, Barbara, you better
make sure no one steals
that, and what in God's name
does it mean?
What if I told her it
meant that I opened
a world-renowned restaurant?
Jesus Christ, what
a story, she'd say.
Some kind of chateau.
Just where the hell
did you come from?"
Thanks.
ADAM WILLIAMS: It was awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
BARBARA LYNCH: Thank you.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Truthful.
So you have seven
restaurants in total, right?
BARBARA LYNCH: Well, eight now.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Eight.
BARBARA LYNCH: Well, I just
partnered with Mario Batali
at Eataly.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Beautiful.
BARBARA LYNCH: It's
my first partnership.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Great.
BARBARA LYNCH: It's going
well, surprisingly so.
ADAM WILLIAMS: How do you
carve out restaurant identities
on the ones that you have?
BARBARA LYNCH: How
do I carve out--
what do you mean?
ADAM WILLIAMS: So like, your
experiences would create you--
like, you went to Italy
when you were younger.
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Was
that your reasoning
for opening Sportello--
that you wanted
to have this counter bar?
BARBARA LYNCH: No, that was my
experience at Brigham's when
I was a kid.
I worked at Brigham's
on Park Street.
It's the same formula
as the counter service.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah.
BARBARA LYNCH: So I was
a waitress and a cook
and a packer for the
gallons of ice cream.
And literally, no one
would show up for work.
So I would serve, flip
grilled cheese or a burger,
pour tea, and then make ice
cream sundaes at the same time,
and cash out, like cashier.
So yeah.
And that formula
is really fabulous.
It really works.
The Butcher Shop was
my first trip to Italy.
You could actually go up--
it was in a little town
called [? Teverina. ?]
And the girl I worked with at
[? McHale's ?] in Cambridge,
right around here, her parents
had bought a house in the '70s.
And she invited me to Italy.
And that was actually
my first trip
where you could go up the
hill to this little bodega
and buy-- well, go to
a wild boar butchering,
buy your meats, fill up
bottles of wine, white or red,
have a shot of
[? insanto, ?] get your gas,
buy your cigarettes, and
then go to the market.
That was the butcher shop.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Nice.
BARBARA LYNCH: B and G
Oysters is my Kelly's Landing
experience in Southie.
I would always go
to Kelly's Landing
for fried clams and calamari.
No.
9 was my experience from
the St. Botolph Club.
I used to be a server
at the St. Botolph Club
where my mother worked--
private club, like fine
dining, white tablecloth.
Drink-- I always wanted a dive
bar, but that's way too cool.
ADAM WILLIAMS: It's kind of
the opposite of a dive bar.
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah.
My brother used to own the Quiet
Man Pub in Southie across from
Triple O's.
Menton is my travels--
well, that was supposed
to be my swan song.
So I guess that's not happening.
What else do I have?
ADAM WILLIAMS: What
else do I have.
BARBARA LYNCH: Stir.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Stir.
BARBARA LYNCH: That's the same
kitchen as my kitchen at home,
but just a smaller version.
With severe ADD, I
just opened that,
because I knew I was
opening three restaurants.
So I could cook in that kitchen,
so I knew where everything was.
And I think I got it all.
ADAM WILLIAMS: And
they're all in Boston.
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah.
ADAM WILLIAMS: You haven't
gone anywhere else?
You haven't taken
your show to Vegas?
BARBARA LYNCH: No.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Is
there a reason why?
Is there reason
why you just want
to stay in Boston, or you--
BARBARA LYNCH: I'd
gamble too much.
Well, Boston, first of all,
I felt like it needed--
I knew what I wanted.
And Boston didn't
have it at the time.
And I'm also a community girl.
I have to have a purpose.
And I love the city.
So part of history.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Thank you for staying and not
taking your show anywhere else.
BARBARA LYNCH: Thank
you for being here.
This is great.
ADAM WILLIAMS: So is there a
distinctive Barbara Lynch-style
of food?
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah,
I would think so.
I think it's like fucked
up Italian and French.
I always say, it's like--
ah, geez, I think it's
like Italian twisted
or classical European
food with a flair.
So Italians would never
put foie gras in a ravioli.
That's just way too
out-of-the-box for them.
And the French really don't
go out of the box either.
So they're very generation,
generation, generation.
So it's just my take
on their classics.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Did
your Southie background
and your rebellionous
kind of ways lead to that?
BARBARA LYNCH: You could call
it a shortcut kid kind of style.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Shortcut
kid kind of style.
So I know that you're
really big in education.
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah.
ADAM WILLIAMS: You didn't
graduate high school.
You didn't finish high school.
BARBARA LYNCH: No.
I was like two points
shy of graduating.
Plus, it was the height
of forced busing.
So I was a really terrible
student in high school,
but a young entrepreneur
in high school.
I pretty much was a
boogie in high school.
And I knew how to make
money at a young age.
So my mom put me in
a parochial school
that had just started because
of the forced busing era.
And I wasn't doing so well.
And so the second year,
she pulled me out.
I got bused to Madison Park
High, which was really chaotic.
It was like a war zone.
So I would skip out
usually at 10:00
and probably sold
some marijuana maybe.
I don't know.
ADAM WILLIAMS: It happens.
BARBARA LYNCH: And so I had
a lot of time on my hands,
and I was pretty
creative from 10:00 on.
And then I had a really
great home ec teacher.
And she saw talent in me.
So she went to my
guidance counselor
and said, if this kid doesn't
take cooking for four years,
then she won't even
stay in school.
And so I literally stayed
in school for four years.
But those two points
shy, they wanted
me to come back and
go to summer school.
And I'm like, oh,
no, no, no, I am way
too busy for summer school.
But later on, when I started
to get accolades as a chef,
the headmaster Tom Hennessy
came by with [INAUDIBLE],
who was the guidance counselor,
and gave me my diploma.
So that was pretty lucky.
ADAM WILLIAMS: So
you have a daughter.
BARBARA LYNCH: I do.
ADAM WILLIAMS: I
have a daughter.
BARBARA LYNCH: How old?
ADAM WILLIAMS: She's eight.
She's crazy, as all
8-year-olds can be.
BARBARA LYNCH: Mine's
13, and it's-- whew.
ADAM WILLIAMS: So
I have five years.
BARBARA LYNCH: Up and
down, up and down.
ADAM WILLIAMS: What do you
teach your daughter about food
and I guess in school and life?
BARBARA LYNCH: She teaches me.
Are you kidding?
She's my toughest critic.
She's been telling me since
four like, Mom, you don't even
know how to cook popcorn right.
She puts the Post-It
sticker on the microwave.
And she points the arrow
to the Popcorn button.
And I was like, oh,
this is how it is.
And gently, she'll
take the pasta bowl
and walks over to the
sink and just smiles at me
and then empties
out the water, which
means it's too much water in
the pasta, or it's too much oil.
ADAM WILLIAMS: She teaches
you how to do pasta?
BARBARA LYNCH: Huh?
ADAM WILLIAMS: She teaches
you how to do pasta?
BARBARA LYNCH: Well,
she'll just gently tell me
how much she doesn't
like it right now.
But she can filet a salmon.
She makes the 45-minute
scrambled eggs.
We go clamming.
She can scrub clams, steam them.
ADAM WILLIAMS: No fear.
BARBARA LYNCH: No.
ADAM WILLIAMS: That's good.
That's a good thing to have.
What about as far as teaching
her about how the farm-to-table
movement is a big thing and
how we use our resources,
as far as locally and as far as
how we treat the earth and how
you as a chef could teach her--
do you incorporate
any of that with her?
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah, yeah.
She's taught that in school now.
And actually, I put
her into a farm school
during the summer vacation.
It's called [? White Log ?]
Farm in Winchester.
She loves it.
So she knows more about
composting than I do
and recycling.
So we're on it.
Farm-to-table--
yeah, she knows it.
Well, my best
friend's Ana Sortun,
so we vacation all summer.
And Ana's really
earthy, crunchy.
That's how we live.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Nice.
And Ana Sortun, she wrote
a foreword for your book.
BARBARA LYNCH:
Oh, she did, yeah.
She did.
And she wrote a quote
on the back, too.
Yeah.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah.
So how did your relationship
with her come about?
You had a lot of great people
write forewords for you
on your book.
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah,
[? Yotam, ?] too.
Yeah.
ADAM WILLIAMS: And
I think it's great
that you had her, being from
Cambridge or around here.
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah.
Ana started cooking at the--
it's no longer here-- but
at the Trident Bookstore
Cafe on Newbury Street.
How old are you?
ADAM WILLIAMS: I'm 38.
I don't know it.
BARBARA LYNCH: Oh, you
wouldn't even know.
Yeah.
So at the Trident
Bookstore Cafe,
I think is now
Stephanie's on Newbury.
And I didn't know Ana then.
But I had just started cooking.
But it was a place I
used to go for lunch,
because I knew I could
have a bowl of soup
and read cookbooks
at the same time.
I was like, fuck, this
is delicious food.
And then she started working
at Casablanca in Cambridge.
And I was working
at the Harvest.
And so then we met.
And she was all of
like 20, and I was 21.
So we have been
friends for 30 years.
And then we used to vacation
together in Westport,
Mass with [? Esan ?] and Steve
Johnson and [? Cat ?] Sleary
and a guy called Charlie
Robinson who used to own Eat
in Cambridge.
And we vacationed for like 12
years Westport, same house.
And now we vacation in Truro.
And her daughter is a
year younger than mine.
And now they just
Facebook each other.
It's better than playdate,
because she lives in Sudbury,
and I live in Winchester,
Gloucester kind of thing.
Yeah.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Nice.
BARBARA LYNCH: And she
teaches me about spices,
and I teach her
how to make pasta.
ADAM WILLIAMS: She
teaches you about spices?
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah.
She is--
BARBARA LYNCH: She's like
the mayor of Istanbul.
You should go to Turkey
with her sometime.
Fun.
ADAM WILLIAMS: This book
that you've just written--
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Why now?
It just seems like
you have so much
going on with all
your restaurants, all
your individual things
you have going on.
And then to stop and write
a book, and this book--
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah, it
actually took like five years.
But I had to Google
it, what's a memoir?
Oh, my god, I did not
want to write this.
Because first of all, I felt
too young to write this.
And then what comes after this,
like the Lifetime Achievement
Award?
And I never had an agent before.
But this woman
from New York read
about a story that
was written about me
in the business section
of the "New York Times"
about five years ago.
And man, did she hound
me to write a book,
because I have a
story to tell, and it
would be very powerful
and inspirational
for other people--
not just women, but for
underprivileged and just
for people in general to--
you can do anything you
want if you want it.
And so she talked me into it.
And then here it is.
And you know what?
I think the timing is
actually perfect right now
with the way the world is.
And so it is good timing.
And it's doing great.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Excellent.
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah.
ADAM WILLIAMS: And what do
you hope your readers will
take away from it?
What do you want them to see?
BARBARA LYNCH: I want
them to know that they
can do anything they want.
I want them to be inspired--
that if I can do this with zero
education and pretty, really
humble upbringing,
then they can do it.
Not just open a restaurant, but
they can do anything they want.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Have you
gotten over your insecurities?
BARBARA LYNCH: No,
but most of them.
Yeah.
Now I'm kind of
happy who I am now.
I'm pretty confident--
more confident, tougher.
ADAM WILLIAMS:
Tougher than before?
BARBARA LYNCH: And
gentler at the same time.
ADAM WILLIAMS: I can
see how that works.
Tough when you have to be.
BARBARA LYNCH: I'm
smarter, put it that way.
When I say I'm more
confident, I guess I'm more--
now I love business part, too.
I'm confident in cooking.
I got it.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah,
I can't see how
you'd have any insecurities,
from what well I've
seen over your years.
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah, I come
across as really tough.
But man, I'm like a teddy bear.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Really?
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah.
Soft.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Oh, I was scared.
BARBARA LYNCH: I got a heart.
ADAM WILLIAMS: In
your book, you talk
about cooking as the
drama of creation,
even a miracle in the making.
Can you describe a recent
miracle in your kitchen--
in one of your kitchens or
in the kitchen-- whatever
you call your kitchen.
BARBARA LYNCH: I
say a miracle is
like when you kind
of invent a dish,
because food's
already been invented.
So I'm not really
into molecular.
But a dish like a
pruned-stuff gnocchi
has never been made
before, that I know of.
ADAM WILLIAMS: I've
never seen it before.
BARBARA LYNCH: Right.
You can't find it in a
recipe book, except for mine.
ADAM WILLIAMS: I've
tried to copy it.
BARBARA LYNCH: You did?
ADAM WILLIAMS: I did.
BARBARA LYNCH: How'd it go?
ADAM WILLIAMS: Sorry.
BARBARA LYNCH: That's fine.
I'm flattered.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah, I used
prunes in a dish once--
pasta dish.
BARBARA LYNCH: How'd it go?
ADAM WILLIAMS: I
thought it was OK.
It definitely was not No.
9 Park.
BARBARA LYNCH: But that's OK.
ADAM WILLIAMS: But
I tried, you know?
BARBARA LYNCH: That's your dish.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah.
But you definitely
inspired me to go out
and try different things.
BARBARA LYNCH: Well,
that's awesome.
That's good.
And then the butter
soup at Menton
is just butter and shellfish
and milk and honey.
But I don't think anybody made
butter soup before either.
But it's good butter.
It's like 87% butter.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Wow.
BARBARA LYNCH: Fat-- butter fat.
But we have cows in Vermont.
And she's absolutely brilliant.
And it's the way she feeds
the cows-- so wild flowers
and hops.
ADAM WILLIAMS: And
you have your own cow?
BARBARA LYNCH: Well,
we lease the cows.
And it's the most
expensive butter ever.
She makes butter for
me and Thomas Keller.
I think we're the crazy
chefs that will do it.
But it's also
supporting a farmer.
She's a one-woman show.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah,
that's a great thing.
BARBARA LYNCH: She's amazing.
She's up in Orwell, Vermont--
Animal Farm, Diane St. Clair.
ADAM WILLIAMS: I
will look her up.
BARBARA LYNCH: She makes
amazing buttermilk, too.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Probably
really expensive buttermilk.
BARBARA LYNCH: Probably.
But she's always growing
and experimenting.
And finally, she's
got some help.
She trusts somebody to
help her make cheese.
So she's starting to make
cheese and more things.
She loves her cows.
And it shows in the butter.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah, and if
you're going to just turn that
into a butter soup--
BARBARA LYNCH: Looks interesting
on the [INAUDIBLE], cows.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Chefs on TV
and the public fascination
with this--
is it something you see
yourself trying to do?
BARBARA LYNCH: What's the show--
"Chef's Table" or something?
I think that's like
the history of a chef.
I don't really watch it.
But the good and the
bad-- the good thing
is that there's an
audience out there.
The reality shows are crazy.
But there is an audience
out there that watches it.
I just wish that there were more
shows that are teaching people
how to cook instead of judging
them how to cook because
of the audience.
And you would learn a lot more.
Right?
ADAM WILLIAMS: Definitely.
BARBARA LYNCH: What I find
fascinating is the age group
that is actually cooking,
which is the 13-,
14-year-olds that want to cook
and want to learn how to cook.
My daughter and her
group of friends
are just friggin' crazy.
They're doing their
own "Top Chefs"
in the kitchen, which
I don't stop it,
because although
they're making a mess,
it's like, wow, they're
just experimenting.
And they're making cakes.
And they're just
crazy in the kitchen.
That is a good thing, which if
there were better shows that
were really kind of fun--
like a Julia Child cooking
show again would be amazing.
From beginning to
end would be great.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Instead
of just showing off--
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah,
potato five ways
or the basics and knife skills
would be amazing, from consomme
to stocks, et cetera.
It would be a great thing.
But then we wouldn't be held
captive by packaged foods.
And perhaps we wouldn't be
obese if we taught more cooking
healthy.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Well,
there's your next job.
BARBARA LYNCH: I don't know.
I'm not a really good teacher.
But who knows?
ADAM WILLIAMS: Who knows?
BARBARA LYNCH: Who knows?
ADAM WILLIAMS: I see it.
BARBARA LYNCH: You do?
ADAM WILLIAMS: I do.
BARBARA LYNCH: Maybe me and you?
ADAM WILLIAMS: That'd be nice.
BARBARA LYNCH: All right.
Let's do it.
Live at Google--
ADAM WILLIAMS: We're
going open up Q&A
if anybody has a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Barbara.
BARBARA LYNCH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
BARBARA LYNCH: Oh, thank you.
Thanks for waiting.
AUDIENCE: Earlier
you said you're
tougher, kinder, smarter.
BARBARA LYNCH: Tougher,
kinder, smarter.
AUDIENCE: Right, all at once.
Do you have any people
who have inspired you,
in terms of your
management style,
either inside or outside of
your industry that maybe you've
read about or that
you've met with who
have helped you become smarter?
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah,
but I forget his name.
He used to run the LA Lakers.
AUDIENCE: Jerry Buss?
ADAM WILLIAMS: Jerry Buss.
BARBARA LYNCH: Was there
another one before that?
AUDIENCE: Jerry
West, Jerry Buss.
BARBARA LYNCH: I think so.
AUDIENCE: OK, tell us why.
BARBARA LYNCH: Well,
he was a team player.
He wasn't just the coach.
He really insp--
AUDIENCE: Oh, Pat Riley.
BARBARA LYNCH: Pat Riley, yeah.
So when I first started
cooking, I don't know why,
but I loved him.
And I loved the
way he was a coach.
He was just part of the team.
And that really inspired
me from my first--
I want to say my first
five restaurants.
And then it was more about
kind of feeding the masses.
So you can't really be
snobbish about what you want
and what you want to cook.
You have to feed what
the public wants.
Throw a little bit
of creativity in it,
so you can get the world in.
And then you'll shine.
Honestly, I could eat a
peanut butter and jelly
sandwich every day.
But I love the craft of cooking.
I'm not a foodie-foodie.
But I love the
process of cooking.
So there's another book
that I read about creativity
and how to survive it and
how to be successful at it.
I forget the name
of the book, though.
Management style-- probably
Danny Meyer, too, "Table Talk."
AUDIENCE: You mentioned teaching
people to cook and things
like knife skills.
What other stuff
like knife skills
should people learn who want
to actually learn how to cook?
BARBARA LYNCH: At home, too?
Yeah, sharpening stones-- do
you have a sharpening stone
at home anyone?
The whetstones?
Yeah, I would say,
just take time.
It's really
therapeutic, actually,
if you use a whetstone.
And it usually takes about
a half an hour a knife.
But you can YouTube
it and Google it,
and they'll show
you how to do it,
because I think if your
knife is really sharp,
it takes about a second
to chop a carrot.
But if you don't, it
really is like torture.
I think knife skills and really
prepping ahead mise en place
is key.
And then cooking is
so easy after that.
And I'm a huge induction fan.
I don't know if
anybody has induction.
Yeah, love it.
Fast, clean, really
clean, holds temperatures,
and it's just awesome.
But teaching to cook is like--
I guess once you
get the basics down,
then you can just
fly through it.
And also, use your fridge.
Clean out your fridge
and just use it up.
And one pot wonders
are always fun, too.
Just be creative.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I
was wondering, what
do you think has been more
a part of you-- being a chef
or being an entrepreneur?
BARBARA LYNCH: Chef first.
Entrepreneur was crazy.
I think I remember
when somebody said,
she's a serial entrepreneur.
I had to Google that.
I was like, wow, what is that?
But now I like being
an entrepreneur,
because it just creates
more jobs within.
And I love to see the staff.
It's also fun to set
them up for success.
It makes me feel
like a grandmother.
But it's also really
fun to see them succeed.
It's also fun to see some come
back when they leave too soon.
And then they come back.
And we're going to go through
another really big growth
spurt, which is
going to be exciting.
And this time, we might
go global, so even better.
So yeah, it's
entrepreneurship now.
Now I'm ready for it.
Before, I wasn't.
And before, I wasn't ready
to be a chef-chef, either.
So you learn.
I've been cooking
for 32 plus years.
So you go through
that experiment stage
and too much shit on a plate.
Now it's just, perfection.
And I'll never be happy
with what I'm cooking.
I'll always learn--
always learning.
But I know I don't want
molecular in my life.
I just don't.
I love textures.
AUDIENCE: Have you considered
going outside your wheelhouse
of French and Italian?
BARBARA LYNCH: At home, I do.
Yeah.
Burmese, I love Thai,
I love Middle Eastern.
Yeah.
But I don't want a
restaurant like that,
because that's just not--
because I'll always fall
back on Italian and French.
I love cooking Indian food.
Oh, my god.
It's all about the
pantry, really.
If you have all the
ingredients, that's so fun.
But I know I'll always go back.
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit
about the biggest differences in
what you learned or experienced
in business between
your first restaurant
and your last restaurant?
How hard was it to
launch as a non-brand,
compared to launching
now as a brand?
BARBARA LYNCH: Hmm.
It got a little easier.
It just got more expensive.
I'm kind of talk about the
development-wise or real
estate.
Brand-wise, I had to
realize that I'm the brand.
And I think that
was really hard.
I think it's hard to realize
that Barbara Lynch was
the brand.
And it was also hard to convince
my operations manager that it's
ridiculous to try to brand a
single restaurant as, say, Stir
and then try to brand the
chef who's running Stir,
because after being
open for 12 years,
Barbara Lynch's Stir would go
a lot farther than just Stir.
So we are actually re-branding
the whole brand now.
Instead of Barbara
Lynch [? Group, ?]
it will be just Barbara Lynch's
Stir, Barbara Lynch's 9 Park,
Barbara Lynch's Menton,
because believe it or not,
a lot of people can
eat at the restaurants
and really have no idea that
I own all of the restaurants.
So it's kind of important to
really look at it every five
years and make sure that--
from afar-- step back and
kind of look at the brand
again and make sure it's right.
I had a catering company
called Niche Catour.
That was awful.
The phone call, Nicki Catouri--
oh, my god, what did I do?
And then 9 at Home was
actually much better,
because they knew No.
9.
So No.
9 at Home was a hit, although I
kind of put that one to sleep,
because it was tough to run
a catering company that was--
most of the catering companies
are already grandfathered in.
And hard to run a
catering company
if you don't have
a huge commissary
and catering China,
glassware, silver
in a huge warehouse with
all the rental equipment,
because it's too costly.
Another little "you learn from
your mistakes" kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: So since
you've got a roomful
of geeks here at Google--
BARBARA LYNCH: I love geeks.
I want to hang out.
AUDIENCE: So I want to push
you on this molecular thing
a little bit, because
I like to cook.
But I also, not big on
foams or making spheres
or stuff like that.
But if I'm making
jam, I'll still
pick up [? Terrence ?]
McGee "On Food and Cooking"
and look at how the proteins
bind and the little acid helps.
And I like my sous-vide.
So aside from the mol--
BARBARA LYNCH: I love my
Cryovac machine, though.
AUDIENCE: So the question
is, do you still apprec--
there has been this
huge trend in science
and cooking and understanding
the science of food
and what's happening,
which I think
has made cooking a lot better.
Do you sort of learn from
that and take from that?
Or do you still go
by gut and instincts
and what's worked and history?
BARBARA LYNCH: Well, I'm
not saying the science of--
I love the process
of putting vinegar
in water for quail
eggs, blah, blah, blah,
or why you put vinegar
to poach an egg.
I love that process
of the science, yeah.
I don't like adding--
what the hell.
AUDIENCE: You don't
glue your meat?
ADAM WILLIAMS: [INAUDIBLE]
maltodextrin to everything?
BARBARA LYNCH: No, I don't.
You know what I mean?
I don't like the shit that
goes on my tongue or the way
it feels on my tongue.
I don't like that.
And I'm kind of over the
[? "noma" ?] plating of every
dish.
Everyone looks the same
in that plating world.
That's just me.
We have a round plate,
and everybody plates
a little bit on the edge.
It just fucking gets me mad.
I'm sorry.
Can we go back to the masters,
Jean-Louis Palladin even?
Go back and plate
real food maybe.
Try.
That's just me.
And I'm not knocking
it, because it
would take me another 50 years
to learn how to cook that way.
And I love Harry McGee.
I love him and Wylie Dufresne.
And I'm not knocking it at all.
It takes about five
years to kind of come up
with a dish that
actually works that way.
And it's already been
invented by [? NASA ?] anyway.
It's like, you're taking
chemicals and everything
that they've invented and
trying to put a dish together
that will actually work.
That's torture, man.
That's like a mad scientist
trying to invent something.
I don't know.
Let's spend some of
that time trying to make
healthier food for kids, maybe.
I don't know.
It's kind of hard for me
to wrap my head around it.
AUDIENCE: Cool
BARBARA LYNCH: But
I love science.
So I don't know.
It's just not me.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
BARBARA LYNCH: I'd
run out of time.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Sounds like you're not
into "see how tall you
can make your
dishes on the plate"
as well, which there
was that period--
BARBARA LYNCH: By using the
most expensive Bernardaud China?
No, I'm all right with that.
AUDIENCE: When we talked about
the difference between you
as a chef and an
entrepreneur, would you say,
as an entrepreneur,
do you have a vision--
like OK, five years,
10 years, I want x.
Or are the new restaurants
a little bit more
just like, OK,
inspiration, I need this?
BARBARA LYNCH: As
an entrepreneur,
I'm working on a--
this formula for restaurants
right now has to change.
It's not going to survive.
So yeah, I'm working
on a new sort
of idea of what a restaurant
formula would look like--
self-sustainable restaurant.
You might have to have
a whole building where
indoor gardening,
slaughterhouse, retail--
like a small Eataly, basically.
But also, your staff,
apartments upstairs,
stay, eat, and
shop kind of thing.
That kind of thing, or
little mini agriturismos.
Who knows?
It's going to change.
It can't sustain it this way.
Or malls are declining.
Maybe malls become the
new farmer's markets.
But that's OK, because
it's evolution.
So things are going to change.
It's going to change.
I love change.
And I love
entrepreneurialship, too.
So online banking for
women or under-privileged--
let's get them started.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: You've got seven--
no, eight-- restaurants.
You're an entrepreneur.
You're starting more.
How much do you actually
get to cook and where?
BARBARA LYNCH: Good question.
There's really no room
in the kitchen because
of the chain of command.
And if I'm in there
and get pulled away--
if I start changing
menus on the line
and get pulled away
for other projects,
it's just a shit show.
So I mentor the chefs at home.
So I have them come
up like on a Tuesday.
And I have a million cookbooks.
So I get to hang out with one
from each restaurant alone.
We pretty much will
read cookbooks all day.
And I'll either cook with them,
or we'll go out to dinner.
We'll go fishing.
We'll go to the farmer's market,
or we'll go to certain farms
that I like.
And then the next
day, we'll generally
cook for 10 random people.
And then we hang out
again the next day,
and we'll chit-chat more.
And I get to really know
them heart and soul.
And then we'll do it a few more
times from each restaurant.
And that way, I get
a lot more out of it.
I get to see how
they cook and where
they want to go next
within the company
or without, what
are their goals.
And it's a much better way
to cook with them that way.
I still love cooking.
And I actually
entertain a lot at home.
But my limit is six people.
Six to eight is
the most to have--
I like to have
good conversations.
So I limit my china
and silverware.
I don't want to have
any more than that.
Usually 10 is the top.
But that's just for
that dinner part--
like that part of the dinner.
Am I making sense?
That's when we invite
the 10 people over max.
So I'm picky like that.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Good rule.
BARBARA LYNCH: Yeah?
ADAM WILLIAMS: Yeah.
BARBARA LYNCH: Do you
like to cook at home?
ADAM WILLIAMS: I do.
I do.
I'm sort of--
BARBARA LYNCH: Busy?
ADAM WILLIAMS: A little
bit, but also handcuffed.
My wife is big
nutritional fan, so lot
of quinoas and farros and stuff
like that and keep it simple.
But I do.
I love to cook at home.
But I'm going to start
throwing out my silverware now.
Like, I don't have
enough, sorry.
Question?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
having humble upbringings
and then having
a lot of success.
Did you have to overcome
any guilt because of that?
That make sense at all?
BARBARA LYNCH: Guilt?
I've always felt
like I'm a shortcut
kid or, how do I get here?
Like, oh, my god, yeah.
Yeah, I still feel
a little shocked.
I don't really
look at it anymore.
I didn't really look at
what I've done up until now.
But now I look at it
and go, oh, my god,
I guess I've really
done a lot with--
a lot of restaurants.
And this whole time
thing, I was like, shit.
An Uber guy said,
holy cow, there's
70 billion people in the
world-- or 7 billion people
in the world?
I was like, oh,
god, don't tell me
that, I really like my
world-- my really small world.
So I can't think of--
I don't think
about it like that.
I think I still am in
a tunnel vision world.
And I kind of like it.
But I'm not done yet.
So I guess that's it.
I don't feel guilty
as much anymore.
I feel more confident,
because I used
to have those carrots
that I used to go after.
Like I always wanted to be
Joel Robuchon or Alain Ducasse.
And finally, finally, I
think at age 50, I said,
I'm really happy to
be Barbara Lynch.
So that's when you
know you're happy.
But I'm not done.
So yeah.
So that's good-- good
to be not done yet.
I haven't learned enough yet.
So I love learning more,
if that makes sense.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for coming.
BARBARA LYNCH: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So as you've risen and
kind of expanded in your career
and in Boston, what are
some of the hardest roles
and jobs you've had
to give up to others
or relinquish to your team?
BARBARA LYNCH: Oh, I think
the hardest was stepping out
of the kitchen.
I think I felt like
a year, I was like--
I floundered for a year.
That's when I felt the
guiltiest-- leaving the kitchen
and still wearing a chef's
coat and just walking
around and feeling useless.
When I say, there is
no room on the line,
there were times I
jumped in on the line
and would send somebody
out, get off the line.
And it just kind of causes
a lot of chaos and stuff.
But believe me, I did it.
And I will do it if
I still feel like--
if anyone's literally
not cooking correctly.
But I think that's
just letting go.
You have to let go and delegate.
That's when you got to really
find your voice and be tougher.
That's when you've got
to really find that voice
to say, oh, my god, how many
times did I fucking tell you,
Jesus, I hate mesclun salad.
There are vegetable
salads you can--
that is when you have
to say, third time, I'm
not saying it again,
because I still
do the menus with the chefs.
And now I draw them and
paint them and write it out.
And what part of that
did you not understand?
Then you got to get tougher
and tougher and tougher
and tougher.
And that took a few years.
So I think that was the
toughest challenge for me
to really switch that position.
But you have to do it
if you want to grow.
And you have to delegate.
And that's when you
have to get tough.
So that was the tough part.
And
Accept it that you are
a businesswoman as well.
Chef owner slash businesswoman--
but the chef owner
comes first and
then businesswoman.
And you have to remember it.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.
BARBARA LYNCH: Oh,
my god, thank you.
ADAM WILLIAMS: Thank you.
BARBARA LYNCH: Thanks.
Great questions.
[APPLAUSE]